[Music]
so welcome everyone to our distributed
ledger technology partnerships talk my
name is Annie ma Weaver and I manage
technology partnerships for Google cloud
focused on our priority verticals
including financial services so Google
cloud public cloud in general and the
Google cloud in specific is a really
good fit for financial services because
of the specific pain points of that
industry and also the pain point of
legacy IT which plates all enterprises
I'm not going to insult you by reading
for my slide but instead I'm going to
speak over it because I think that's
it's just a helpful way to compliment
and illustrate things over the best year
year-and-a-half we've seen a lot of
momentum and financial services with
customers and partners and over the next
couple days at next I wanted to
highlight some of those financial
services customer and partner sessions
where you can really hear about it
straight from them
I have not listed sessions that have
already happened because we have not
invented time travel yet
so distributed ledger technology or DLT
is relevant to more than financial
services as I've been talking with
customers and partners we've heard about
use cases across multiple verticals and
I'm really excited about the potential
of these applications but many of them
as you know are nascent
and we want to be the public cloud upon
which developers build these use cases
and figure out which of them are really
the the ones that are meant to scale and
I've meant to be widely adopted the
question I get often is you know why are
companies looking at DLT and there are a
lot of potential benefits around cost
trust and security but many of them are
still potential ones and that's where I
think Google cloud can help we can be a
platform upon which you can take your
ideas and you can bring them to fruition
and then these potential benefits can be
realized so I'm excited to announce it
as we also announced in a blog post
yesterday that you can now develop DLT
solutions on Google cloud you can do
them in a DIY fashion with our open
source integrations with two leading DLT
platforms hyper ledger and aetherium or
if you need more advice and help through
the process you can work with our
partners digital asset and block apps
who will soon be speaking to you more
about what they do and how they're
working with us so to summarize we have
both DIY and also proprietary
partnerships that enable you to build
DLT applications on GCP these will be
available through the cloud market cloud
launcher market which we're now
rebranding as marketplace
so now I'm really excited to invite onto
the stage Blythe masters CEO of digital
asset who will tell you more about this
incredible company and how they're
working with Google cloud Thank You
Annie and hello everyone it's a great
pleasure to be here as you heard I'm
Blythe masters and I'm the CEO of
digital asset a new partner of Google
cloud I'm also a 27 year veteran of JP
Morgan and the former CFO of its global
investment bank and back in 2015 I came
across a nascent team of developers
academic cryptographers and even former
traders and one former tank commander
who had an extreme Drive and Technology
Vision whose implications if I'm really
honest neither they nor even I truly
understood at the time so what made me
lose my mind one day back in 2015
given my background and go sign up for a
microscopic startup in the tech space
with no technology background I'm a
business person by background in what
was literally a five person team plus a
dog the answer lies in a big idea an
idea that's big enough to have material
financial implications and certainly
easily big enough to make a big career
bet on the idea of course was blockchain
back in 2015 everyone thought that
blockchain was all about crypto
currencies and actually some of you may
be forgiven for still feeling that way
today but the reality is that blockchain
is a lot bigger than crypto currencies
and the applications go far and wide
so here three and a half or so years
later is the vision of our company
digital assets
simply put we believe the blockchain
offers the opportunity to unleash the
kind of furiously paced innovation that
the tech industry has become accustomed
to over the past 10 years and yet which
has been notably absent from financial
services and other giant enterprise
sectors from healthcare to gov tech and
beyond it will revolutionize the
processing of every asset every
transaction every workflow across and
within every business in different
companies in the world it's not a small
vision now to understand this just with
any great technology solution you need
to understand what is the problem that
is being solved 15 years ago if you had
predicted that we would see the advent
of self-driving cars more quickly than
we would discover the ability to sell an
equity and get your cash for that in
less than 2 days or it even you'd have
the simple privilege of working walking
from one doctor's office to the next and
expecting your medical records and
identity to travel with you you would
have been declared insane but the
reality is that we got the self-driving
car first how on earth could that be the
case well the answer lies in something
as banal and mundane as data
architecture it turns out that
enterprise infrastructure from financial
services to health care and Beyond has
been stymied by what we call silo
ization why because businesses can't
securely trust or could not until now
their ability to share and process data
without compromising their
responsibility for their books and
records and confident confidentiality
and privacy
now what silos lead to is unnecessary
duplication of
backwards error-prone updates asymmetric
information expensive and time-consuming
breaks and literally in financial
services alone tens of billions of
dollars a year in a completely zero
value-added effort of reconciling that
means ticking and tying records that are
different that should in fact be the
same simply because they didn't share a
common or golden source of record it was
my exposure over almost 30 years in the
bowels of the financial services
industry to the understanding of the
sheer scale of the cost the waste the
inefficiency and ultimately the risk
associated with this that led me to
believe all in in blockchain and to move
to digital asset blockchain or as it has
become known as DLT distributed ledger
technology will change all of this
simply put it's a new form of secure
database architecture that offers
businesses enterprise for the first time
certainty of shared real-time identical
records synchronized processing
programmable automatable assets and
associated workflows without loss of
privacy or confidentiality and without
continuing to have responsibility for
being able to independently validate
your own books and records just as the
internet unleashed and liberated the
free flow of information twenty years
ago and changed everything
blockchain is going to liberate the
processing of value saving hundreds of
billions of dollars of cost and
unleashing innovation to hear more about
how this will happen I'll introduce you
to two of my colleagues our CTO shock
fear and our chief marketing officer
Donna pray
Thank You Blythe so what do we mean when
we say unleashing web-based innovation
that's a very tall order to to fill and
we're being hosted here by Google a
company who's really been that that
forefront of web-based innovation and
we've been hearing for the past few days
about amazing infrastructure or mutual
eyes infrastructure things like Basel
and kubernetes and the continuous
integration and continuous deployment
pipelines that Google has and what those
mutual eyes infrastructures have done
they have really optimized for rate of
change going to do saying a high rate of
change and enabling developers to ship
fast ship high quality and and should be
efficiently to their customers new
functionality with very quick iteration
times now we don't have that today in in
the domain of cross enterprise business
dealings when we look at the largest
enterprises that networks networks
across enterprises of finance healthcare
government developers don't have that
same agility that they have within one
company when I came out of low-level
development doing cryptography and x86
architecture and wanted to launch a
business I had to read a few tutorials
to read a few books and very quickly
learning things like rails and angular
and cloud api's I was able within a
matter of weeks to go and and deploy a
new business so that that really blew my
mind how fast you can be efficient and
that doesn't exist when you look at how
things are working today across
enterprises and that's what we want to
bring through having neutralized
infrastructure having one infrastructure
that's deployed that takes care of all
of the heavy lifting and allows the
developers to think about the business
flows that they're trying that they're
developing and we ask ourselves every
day what kind of innovation what kind of
acceleration can we do in for the
brightest the best and brightest college
grads of tomorrow will be able to do a
pull request or be able to launch their
business deeply integrated from the
start into those networks that are
already deployed across these large
large enterprises and if they won't have
to think
about deploying software for one
enterprise in a silo for one company but
can now start thinking about the broad
picture about what it looks to do cross
cross enterprise workflows so there's a
ton of buzz and hype around blockchain
and the question is what is it what is
it that's unique about this offering
about the digital asset SDK and platform
and about this joint offering with
Google cloud that's going to enable what
we're saying enable unleashing web-based
innovation so what does that mean for
your business so damn all the digital
asset modeling language is a new small
contract language developed by digital
asset to a short said abstract away the
underlying infrastructure so you don't
need to worry about the cryptography or
the distribution or notifications or
privacy you just focus on the business
of your business what drives value to
your customers and let the language and
the platform take care of everything
under behind-the-scenes in addition to
that we announced yesterday that damn
old platform as a service on Google
cloud similarly just lets you focus on
the application build something that
delivers value do not worry about
configuring the platform deploy figuring
the network deploying the software and
the underlying infrastructure so
together this enables rapid prototyping
for your business shorter time to market
building distributed ledger applications
they can deliver vast rare value faster
and sooner than otherwise possible and
enabling you to be more agile to
changing customer demands regulatory
requirements or market forces so you've
all heard about public blog chains and
in public buck chains what those have
achieved essentially getting data
integrity across a large scale
deployment or getting consent is getting
consensus over data across a large group
of of entities via people or companies
and synchronizing those views and that
that is a huge achievement
what most public machines don't deal
with very well is data confidentiality
we get the data integrity we get that
synchronized view but everyone gets that
same view and they're different there
are varying degrees of confidentiality
some do get it right but what they
struggle dealing with is dealing with
very complex or generic workflows the
types of workflows we have in most large
enterprises today now don't get me wrong
this is a huge thing and it's a great
solution to a specific set of problems
but it's for that specific set of
problems what we did I digitized it when
we started we were a group of
cryptocurrency enthusiasts and
developers and we said how do we take
the same inspiration of the same types
of solutions and apply it to a different
domain to the domain of large cross and
reply apprised workflows now in the
private dispute larger space we see a
lot of attempts to achieve
confidentiality by really selling data
or using techniques such as encryption
zero knowledge proof or overlay networks
on top of a base network to now
compartmentalize the data what most of
those solutions do is they trade-off
integrity or in many cases liveness and
it's a bit too much to dive deep I would
love to go in deeper in this stuff but
we talk much more in depth about this in
our blog and I urge everyone to go to da
ml count to see how we thought about
these trade-offs between integrity
privacy and liveness so what did we do
with the digital asset platform through
a series since 2014 of working with very
large potential customers and today
customers we went through a series of
increasingly complex MVPs on building a
platform and we actually started from
those public blockchain roots which was
my background in my alma mater and zero
knowledge proof what we actually found
out is that the hardest problem that
needed to get solved was the problem of
data architecture of how do you
structure your data in a way that
preserves integrity across the
distributed system where not everyone
has our data so I also preserve privacy
and also preserves liveness that the
network can't stop when you when you
maintain those other two properties the
integrity and the privacy
what we did is we built a formal
modeling of what the data should look
like on a distributed ledger then we
built a domain-specific language again
through a series of MVPs and
understanding deeper what those use
cases are of our clients we built a
domain-specific language that forces the
developer to structure the data in such
a way that is amenable to distributed
Ledger's on the other side we wanted it
to be very efficient so it lets the
developer only think about their
business use case about their business
workflow and not have to think about the
infrastructure that that they're
deploying to what we got to is a
platform that does real-time
reconciliation across all of the nodes
in the network is auditable analyzable
extensible and when you build workflows
you can use those common workflows and
reuse them
so if someone builds a library or a
module you can then reuse that workflow
and again build on top of the shoulder
shoulders of giants demo or the digital
asset modeling language that's the
language that we created and that's the
surface or the API that a developer sees
they build using this language and that
that that gets deployed to pretty
complex infrastructure demo is a purpose
is it is a language that was built
bottom-up purchased built for the domain
of dispute letters what we've seen in
the public boxing space and I'm sure
everyone has heard about these are very
very public bugs that cost stakeholders
in the hundreds of millions of dollars
now that's simply something we can't
allow in our domain some clients are
using our SDK today to model businesses
that run daily volumes in the trillions
of dollars so typical transaction size
is in the hundreds of millions of
dollars
we can't allow above now those bugs that
happen in the public button space aren't
because developers aren't skilled these
were very very skilled developers it's
because they lack the right tools to
build these types of workflows in a
secure manner there are we believe
there's their specific domains that are
mission-critical that require the type
of frameworks for that in the past in a
prior life I was I was operating and
maintaining missile defense systems that
were defending protecting my life
protecting my shipmates lives and I'm
extremely grateful that none of those
were written in JavaScript
and we took that approach we took that
approach of building something that's
that's purpose-built
for this domain what we came up with was
with which was demo and that's a
language that really abstract away the
ledger details and that's the offering
that we're making available on Google
Cloud as of yesterday spoke a new model
Endemol our customers and our partners
have built distributed ledger
applications across many different
industries for example virtually when
you think about small contracts what
they really are at their core when you
take away the hype and the fluff our
shared business processes that span
across organizations as such the
potential for the use of demo and smart
contracts more broadly within commerce
is absolutely huge they can cover
anything every asset transaction and
workflow so for example we've been
working with a large Clearing House in
the healthcare space to do
straight-through processing for claims
eligibility and payments to make sure
that the payer and provider and everyone
throughout that value chain sees the
same data in real time medical records
as Clyde mentioned earlier can be
synchronized amongst insurers patients
doctors and hospitals and selectively
reveal only the pertinent piece of
information to each of those entities
our partners of exploring in supply
chain pharmaceutical supply chain
through the manufacturer transport and
sale of drugs many of which there's a
large problem with counterfeiting to
ensure that what you receive at the end
of that supply chain is what was
produced at the beginning complex
processes can be coordinated between
ecommerce sites and fulfillment centers
and payment providers
down to the shipping company to
coordinate all across the value chain
across multiple different distinct legal
entities and many more so we've been
working with partners on managing
software licenses simplifying the
mortgage application process for
insurance reinsurance as well as even
the issuance secondary market and
redemption the use of concert tickets so
as you can see there's a really a broad
application for Dan'l Dan'l can be used
for any multi-party workflow the largest
traction we've seen so far has been
within financial services so you're
gonna see here a list of some of our
investors each of which are exploring
using dam or building gamble driven
applications in their own way banks
stock exchange groups large technology
vendors global systems integrators are
building dam or driven applications for
internal use cases across business lines
bilaterally between two entities or even
as we're plane replacements for entire
markets and these use cases even within
financial services are very varied cash
equities repo collateral management
there's a lot or very very complex
behind-the-scenes processes that you
know most of us are blissfully unaware
of but are vital to the the functioning
of the global economy so these are some
of the most highly regulated and most
demanding customers in the world the
goal is if we can solve for them we can
solve for any commercial use case and I
know that this is no longer a case of
wildy LTC adoption but when and that
leads on to a great case study one of
our marquee clients the Australian
Securities Exchange the ASX who we've
been working with for just over three
years now so the Asics are doing this
for real they're not playing around
anymore they have committed to take into
production a full replacement
scale first financial market
infrastructure projects using a
distributed ledger this is not a POC
this is not a pilot this is a real
production build that is going to
production and it's not a greenfield
application it's not a peripheral
service this is a natural replacement at
the end of this process they will be
switching off their clearing and
settlement system for cash equities and
replacing it entirely with the digital
asset platform and damn so this isn't
mangos on a blockchain this isn't
collectible kitty's this is an
application that really matters if this
goes down the Australian economy is
affected people's pensions are affected
and it's a real mission critical system
every single stock in Australia will be
cleared and settled on a blockchain and
now we're excited to bring that
technology to Google cloud so yesterday
we were delighted to announce that
digital asset and Google cloud have been
collaborating to bring the technology
that you've had been hearing about today
to GCP we announced that Google cloud
have joined the private beta of our
developer program and as such their
solution architects can explore with
their clients applications within
various different industries using tamil
and our technology we also announced the
additional addition of Dan'l pass the
platform as a service hosted on Google
cloud so similarly customers can just
spin that up and quickly and easily
start building applications and later
this year Google will be hosting a
series of developer conferences focused
around amyl and if you are interested in
joining please visit da mo da ml calm
and registering your interest there dan
said we're extremely excited for me this
is a bit of a personal excitement it's
it's paying it forward just like I said
I was mind blown when I started web
development understood seeing how fast
you can deploy a business I'm hoping
that people will be using this in the
future but I know people will be using
this in the future in order to deploy
their businesses at much larger scale
and and really bring that pace that that
you can do things much faster so I wish
we had time for a live demo I'm a coder
and that's what we do but the next best
thing at least we'll talk about a little
bit about what this offering is so first
of all that at the top level layer
waking what you can do is build
applications using all of the best of
the Google cloud infrastructure things
like Google cloud functions and
tensorflow and spanner now I can talk
for hours about why why these offerings
are so fit for purpose for building
applications that connect into a
distributed ledger but just to give a
sense
many of the workflows in the financial
world that that we're working with need
data analysis need risk analysis and and
many types of optimizations and those
are things that we believe will we'll
really be able to leverage machine
learning and for example infrastructure
such as tensorflow
to build very very efficient
applications that connect into a
distributed ledger then you have the
demo SDK and the demo SDK was really
built to allow the developers to very
very quickly reason about a distributed
application across many companies and
not just across one enterprise and we'll
talk about a little bit about that in
the next few slides the SDK builds those
distributed applications that get
deployed onto the DI platform and this
is a di platform that's highly optimized
for Google Cloud leveraging
infrastructure such as the goo the
google kubernetes engine and stack
driver
then you can use managed services either
a managed platform that's managed by a
digital asset or by one of our many
channel partners running on Google Cloud
and managed by a channel partner or you
can use your own Google Cloud account to
deploy either one node or a full network
of nodes you can have one node that
connects into an existing network and
run it on your own Google Cloud account
unless you can automate all of this
through orbit era which really gives you
a few minutes and almost a one-click
type engagement of using the orbit era
marketplace to quickly launch and
configure and deploy a running network
so on the development side on the on the
ID the demo integrated development
environment provides real-time feedback
to the developers as they're writing
code to support efficient development of
correct smart contracts and what we've
been hearing from the channel partners
in their usage of the demo SDK is that
they were amazed at how fast they can go
from nothing to running a POC or an MVP
on a on a running distributed ledger at
at high scale we're very excited with
the announcement yesterday that now the
Google Google's client engineers and
architects have the ability I've joined
our private beta and they have the
ability now to extend to their clients
so for all the Google clients here who
want to hear more about blockchain
applications you can reach out to your
to your account representatives and your
client engineers and they'll be happy to
to work and iterate on solutions further
than that not just MVPs and POCs we've
already gone through a process of three
years of working with very large very
very complex workflows and even there
these are institutions that are very
very used to heavy waterfall development
and we've been receiving amazing
feedback on that front both directly
answer channel partners on the cycle
times of deploying new features as
they're creating these workflows so
they're used to having very very
different stages of deployment building
features testing and now they can really
compress those cycles again into that
same experience that a developer today
in a tech company has having a running
platform and very quickly developing and
deploying and going through that whole
process all the way to developing a
feature
having it signed off by the customer and
going into QA on the testing front
there's an integrated scenario language
which gives a full test-driven
development or behavior driven
development and union unit testing
ability which is baked into the
integrated development environment
there's the sandbox that's always
running in the background so if you make
a mistake if you write a bug it's always
running all of the unit tests in the
background and you'll get immediate and
immediate feedback loop of that sandbox
of a distributed environment that's
running locally on your laptop so you
immediately get that that feedback and
you can click click on those scenarios
and essentially get debug tools a
transaction graph Explorer in the same
view so the developer can see the code
the tests any errors in test and the
transaction graph Explorer at the same
time and have that ability to go in
debug in one one environment and you
know that if it's running in that
environment you can immediately deploy
to the to a robust auto scaling and
highly available infrastructure of
course if you build being an MVP a PLC
or a large production full stack
solution you need the ability to
demonstrate it or you need to the
ability to build UI components so we
have in the SDK auto auto code
generation tools that take whatever
smart contracts and business logic that
you wrote immediately creates a RPC
binding so that you can build
applications in whatever language you
want to build applications there is a
JVM framework if you want to use our
framework in order to get all of the
high availability and auto scaling
properties out of the box you get the
ability to dynamically create front ends
so there's a graph QL backend and it
auto met auto generates the schemas for
that front for that back-end and the
types and it creates react components so
you can immediately get those components
and build your own UI and again the
cycle times on this are really amazing
the speed at which you can get
everything all the way to a front end
and we have two or three developers
building POCs that typically took months
and of course last but not least you
want the ability to deploy and here
we're not talking about deploying
something locally or in one machine or
two machines you really want to deploy
and you want to deploy to a robust
kubernetes cluster that's running in a
bit on Prem private cloud or or a public
cloud and in the case of running it on
the Google cloud running it on a very
highly optimized Google cloud that has
all the tools to operate your
environment and as of our announcement
yesterday and very soon we'll be making
this available that orbitary deployment
that makes it really seamless to go run
and and start operating that network so
it just liked it to be collaborating
with Google cloud to bring the
blockchain solutions to GCP to learn
more about demo
next please visit da ml comm where you
can request early access to our
Developer Program which includes both
access to the Demel SDK developer
preview and the demo platform as a
service which will be rolling out
throughout the course of the year too if
you'd like to see how you can work with
digital assets partner with us to bring
blockchain applications to your industry
please email us a partner as a digital
asset comm Shawn mentioned reach out to
your Google Account Representative and
discuss how they can help assist you
bringing Google cloud-based applications
to your your industry or come chat to
myself shawl or a few of the other
members of the digital asset team after
this session so thank you very much
thank you for having us Annie and back
to you
[Applause]
thank you Dan and shawl that was
fantastic let's give them another round
of applause so following on that I'm
also really excited to introduce the
founder and CEO of another DLT partner
of ours black ops so I'd like to welcome
to the stage Caryn James Lubin thank you
very much
Daniel can you turn me up
better now yeah all right so I'm as any
noted the founder and CEO of block ups
block ups my role is ranged from
actually writing our core back-end
software all the way through to what I
do today which is events like this
interfacing with our partners and our
customers etc so we kicked off in 2015
around the same time as digital asset
which makes us ancient for blockchain
companies and we were sort of more of a
community first sort of company so we're
in the etherium ecosystem and created
the first commercial grade version of
aetherium which fairly early on we
realized could be deployed not just in
the public blockchain configuration
which you've likely heard the most about
but specifically in the enterprise so we
consider ourselves the creator of the
blockchain as a service category which
we kicked off in late 2015 with one of
Google's competitors who I won't name
and are very happy to help bring
blockchain as a service to the Google
cloud platform today so we believe also
we're the first to bring a production
blockchain application online and a
fortune 500 context this is with the
world's largest mining company bhp
billiton in late 2016 and through that
effort we learned a lot about what it
takes for enterprises to adopt
blockchain technology and the fact that
enterprise needs are somewhat orthogonal
to what you see in the public networks
as far as one performance transaction
throughput latency the complexity of the
business logic present in the enterprise
and all the non-functional requirements
compliance privacy etc which commercial
vendors like us help our customers
through where you don't see in the more
open source focused public blockchain
area so in any case we found that a
number of other vendors we're trying to
solve the same problems in the etherium
ecosystem one way to think of what
aetherium is done it's not just a public
blockchain
but it's also a vertical standard and is
something of a platform and we're
finding the the etherium virtual machine
and solidity to sort of be like Java in
the sense that it was invented for one
context Java being invented for embedded
systems programming but is being
deployed in in many other contexts and
becoming a developer focused and a
community standard that enterprises are
also deploying so we got together with
with several of our one large customers
and two technology companies who wanted
to see the adoption of sort of a Java
style standards-based approach to make
blockchain technology a reality in the
enterprise so we're on the funding more
to the enterprise of theorem Alliance
and I personally chair the technical
steering committee that sits out to
define what etherium means in the
enterprise so a little bit on our on our
platform so we again are a platform
provider we sit atop the Google cloud
and on the cloud marketplace and we see
ourselves as built on open standards so
you can think of block chains again as
not just platforms with protocols
protocols for communication and
transactions and so we implement these
protocols and facilitate the creation of
enterprise applications across a variety
of verticals as far as our platform goes
it's sort of split into kind of two core
use cases one the ledger itself so on
the lower side here the virtual machine
which does transaction processing
synchronization which comprises the
peer-to-peer network and the consensus
algorithm that allows everyone to arrive
at the same shared truth and the
database component which allows our
customers to query the blockchain as
they would a traditional relational
database this is all exposed through a
variety of api's which do things like
key management so customers don't have
to think about the nitty-gritty of the
lifecycle of the private keys which
encode the data that's on the blockchain
querying api's that are built out of the
bar
so when you write a smart contract you
have an API for it that front-end
developers can write user interfaces to
without any additional work etc so let's
talk through a few use cases that are
actually deployed in production across a
variety of our customers so obviously
there's a lot of watching adoption and
financial services so that is where we
see it a tremendous amount of our
business and has designed our platform
around a number of the requirements the
use cases like real-time gross
settlement so this is bank-to-bank
intraday transfers so that banks can
cover their liabilities in a very low
latency situation kyc consumer customer
identity management so that customers
may D couple their personal identity
from the information that their
financial institutions have to
streamline onboarding so that they can
consume products across a variety of
financial institutions much more easily
we have sort of a tremendous amount of
work in supply chain so and this is
cross sectors as well
I mentioned the East case with the
world's largest mining company bhp
billiton
but we're deploying supply chain
management software in agriculture in
commodities etc we even have some work
in the government so later this year we
will turn on a production system that
will help departments of Motor Vehicles
track vehicle title electronic lien and
title and vehicle registrations through
their lifecycle and we have a lot of
business in the energy sector as well
which is also a strength of googles
apparently we've been working with the
Google team for maybe five six months
now we actually have a launch customer
for this event so we are happy to
announce a partnership with company
called money catcher
so money Quecha is an australian based
financial services firm that provides -
blockchain platforms based on block apps
Strato one is called reg chain this is
a loan management product and the other
is called home chain
so what their technology allows their
global banking customers to do is
understand the life cycle of loans and
understand all the parameters for
compliance around these loans so there
are a lot of data sources to correlate
when servicing personal loans that fit
the blockchain architecture in a fairly
seamless way and so they've partnered
with us and actually already begun to
launch their application on the Google
cloud so first reference customer
already here a little bit more on what
they do so they're rigged chain product
does risk compliance in reporting again
on the the loan data that we see and
hooks not just in to our platform but
some of the Google's data services would
allow them to do advanced analytics on
the the core data that is in the
blockchain ledger so finally once talked
just a little bit about the technical
integration so we are available on the
Google cloud launcher or the Google
cloud marketplace now our platform is
very easy to use but scales all the way
through real Enterprise production
implications you can see a picture of it
here it has a built in blockchain
Explorer tools for live editing smart
contracts deploying them on the watch in
itself search search across all of the
data that is in the blockchain and very
quickly you'll find that your teams are
your developers will be able to go from
prototyping an application to deploying
that application to production icing it
so we were very happy to partner with
Google on this journey to making
blockchain not just a deployed but you
know at reasonable scale reality now to
taking it to the whole world so thank
you very much again I'm Karen James
Litton from block apps so please one
interact with me after the session to
visit us at
caps net or find us on the good Google
cloud launcher marketplace and three
speak to your Google Account Executives
and use our products on google cloud
marketplace thank you so I have the
tough job of following after those two
fantastic presentation sections so you
know be easy on me
so I'm going to close out with the open
source integrations of hyper ledger
fabric aetherium as I mentioned at the
start we want to be your preferred
public cloud for testing developing and
launching DLT applications and for that
we want to meet you where you are so if
you need help with your building with
your ID ating then you've got really
great partners in digital asset and
block apps but if you're the type that's
more DIY and you want to get your hands
dirty and build from scratch yourself
we're also there for you so the first
integration that I'm happy to share is
of hyper ledger fabric this was built by
a Google engineer it is an open source
integration of open source code you can
start using it today on our Google cloud
launcher now called marketplace and as
you can see it's a click to deploy
option so super excited to share this
because it is something that again you
can start using today we also are
building an open-source integration of
aetherium which will also be available
on marketplace but this being software
development timelines it was supposed to
be done by this week but you know this
week slipped a little so it will be done
I've been told by my engineer who I
don't see here but you know if he's here
looking at you it should be done in a
few weeks in August
so finally I wanted to give a really big
hearty thank you to all of you for
coming and hearing more about what we're
doing with DLT partners and also to our
DLT partners block apps and digital
asset who have been so fantastic to work
with have really taken not just the
technology approach but to Sholes point
also our cultural approach to
development to heart and brought that to
our cloud so we're so excited about this
and as everyone has mentioned if you
have questions come and find us
afterwards thank you
[Music]
you